السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
احنا الرياضيين في خربط يعني دائما في عرض
الاشياء لان متعودين نتكلم عن الرياضه عن
كيف تنزل كيف اختارك يعني كل المواضيع
رياضيات اليوم
مختلف شويه
عن الرياضه يمكن تدخل في موضوع
اليوم موضوعنا
عن شريف تقريبا قبل
120 سنه
في 1903 كان في اثنين فهذاك العصر احنا
ممكن نسميهم مجانين
120 سنه و 130 سنه
كان المجتمع اللي معاهم يعتبرهم انتحارين
هدول الشخصين اتوقع الكابتن محمد احمد
يعرفهم الدوله الاخوان
في 1903
بهذا تاريخ بالضبط كانت لهم اول رحله
طيران ناجحه
يعني كم محاوله يطير وما يقدروا
وتخيل فكره المجتمع بالنسبه لهم
اثنين مجانين
غريبه عجيبه هدول اسهل ناس ممكن يموت يعني
بطريقه جدا سهله منها من ارتفاع
لكن
كانوا مستقيم هم مؤمنين بالفكر اللي معاهم
انهم من الانسان ممكن بتطوير هذه الفكره
واستلموا طبعا
هم رايحين اخوان في طياره واحده تتسعين
مثل ما نشوف الحين الفكره انه
هذا المجسم او هذا الشيء لما يستخدموه
الحين
مستلهم من
الطيور موجوده
عندنا في الارض
بعد المجتمع
يعني طبعا
كان متنمر عليهم يعني
تتبع حيوان الفكره عشان نقتله يعني هذا
الشيء صعب
جميع الكائنات اللي موجوده على وجه الارض
مسخره
لتطوير او تاثير وتهدير حياه افضل للانسان
فبعد هذه الفكره اللي الجريئه اللي كانت
من اخوان سامحوني
يقبل المنطقه
العين بالعالم
انها صحيح برضو احنا نعتبرها الفكره
مجنونه كان
ممكن يتنقلوا من مكان لمكان بشكل اسرع
بشكل افضل
وقاموا في تطوير هذه
هذا الاختراع
وفي
خلال تقريبا 120 سنه من كانت فكره
الانتحاريه ومجنونه
سهل الانسان يموت فيها لشخصين وصلت في
2023 انها تكون اامل وسيله للتنقل في
العمل هذا اول شيء
كانت تحمل شخصين صارت الحين هذه الوسيله
تحمل اكثر من 850
صح
من هذا من هذه المقدمه
بدي ادخل فيها الموضوع
يعني اشوف انه خلال 120 سنه تعتبر فتره
زمنيه بسيطه في 2000 سنه اللي احنا عايشين
فكره كانت جدا مصيبه مستلهمه من كائنات
موجوده على وجه الارض زي ما وصلت الى
موصله عليهم احنا اليوم الحين كيف يعني
صارت للتنقل بسبب ايمان
الظاهر
موضوعنا من خلال هذه الصوره
احنا عايشين
في كره
مساحتها 70% مايه
30% يابسه بالنسبه لي انا موضوع للتفكر
ليش ما ليش ما كان 70% جالسه
30% بحر اكيد في سبب معين يعني خليني انا
افكر زياده في هذا الموضوع واللي زاد
تفكيري
ولذلك تفكيري في هذا الموضوع
انه
نسبه السوائل جسم الانسان 65% طبعا الحين
ما شاء الله
في ترابط في الموضوع
في شيء مختلف
نحاول شوي
في كل مقصود ثاني في
طبعا بما ان
انا اسوي حاليا هو النزول للاعمال بنفس
واحد
الحين مثل ما تشوفوا في الصوره الموجوده
مجموعه
صح ولا لا
وهذه الاسماك
وهذه طبعا معروفه
لكن
كل
في البحر تتنفس عن طريق الخياشي
لكن هل
كل الحيوانات او الكائنات اللي موجوده في
البحر تستخدم الخياطين
اكيد
هذا المصدر الثاني
خليني انا افكر بطريقه جدا مختلفه
انه الدولفين
البرميلات بشكل عام
تستخدم الراهب في العيش والانسليان تحت
الماء هذا بالنسبه للمؤشر
ان الانسان
ممكن يمارس هذا الشيء
من خلال هذا الصوره طبعا هذه صوره لمجموعه
معروفه الدين او لقبيله اسمها التداول
وهم
رزقهم من حياتهم وممارستهم
من خلال هذه الناس
ومن خلال ترابط
ان في كائنات ممكن تعيش في المايك
انا شخصيا تاثرت في هذه الاشياء
وصارت عن مختلف
لكي تكون جمعيه نفس فكره الاخوان 120 سنه
الانسان ممكن
على داخليه مؤمن من الانسان ممكن يعيش
وممكن ان بعد 120 سنه في واحد يقول في نفس
الوقت لانه واقف فيها بيقول لي في مجنون
كان في عمان
قاعد بيحاول وينط الفكرة اللسان ممكن يعيش
تحت
لما وصلوا ان الانسان يبدا يطير
انا بوريكم كيف اذا الانسان تطور في هذا
وتطور نفسك في هذا المجال من خلال حق
زميلي بسيطه عشرين سنه
فسرعه التطور
لهذه الرياضه
وقدرات الانسان زادت ايمان بهذا
طبعا
يقدر يعيش تحت المي 14 دقيقه
والوورد الحين لحبس النفس 12 دقيقه بيني
وبين الدولفين الحين دقيقتين
ثاني شيء
بدايه مسابقات الغوص طبعا احنا بنفس واحد
بدون استخدام
الولد اللي كان في الصوره
في سنه الغواص احمد غواص كانت 73 متر
وفي 2022
اللي هو 132 متر تتخيل
بعد 120 سنه كيف ممكن الانسان ممكن يوصل
في هذا المجال انا ما قاعد اقول لك ان
الفكره ممكن تتحقق مئه بالمئه لكن نعطي
نفسنا مجال من الانسان ممكن يطول هذه
الفكره ممكن انه يوصل
الى ما لا نهايه
المجرات قصص اللي قدامنا
ما في انسان قدره الانسان واتوقع بما انني
اكثر الناس دكاتره عارفين ما شاء الله
امكانيات باسم الانسان وخبايا جسم الانسان
من داخل
فما في
اغلب الناس الموجوده هنا مؤمنين انهم ما
في شيء اسمه
مش ممكن او مستحيل
فاتوقع ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
تحدي بسيط الحين ان شاء الله بنعرض
الفيديو
لاحد
سنتين في سنه 2021
لمشاركه في العالم
وكنت 105 متر واحد
وانت تشوف الفيديو حاول تحب سنه عشان تحس
بالمشاعر تحت
اشوفكم ان شاء الله
درجه حراره المي كانت تقريبا 25
هذا الهدوء التاني
اللي احنا نعيشه
ما نسمع ولا شيء بيني وبين نفسي
الشاشه اكثر راح تشوفهم
41 انا 43 متر هذه
النظاره
الحين نازل في مرحله
الحين ممكن الطفل يقول لك بعد 75 متر
راح يصير كلها
سبحان الله في طبيعه في جسم الانسان
[موسيقى]
يغطي الضغط اللي يصير
فالجسم الانسان مهيا
الشعور
بقول لكم الشعور اللي انا احس فيها الحين
واللي دائما متعود اسويه في هذه اللحظه
انا غالبا
حضوركم
في عندنا مهارات
وهذه المهاره ممكن احنا نطورها حتى
الانسان
لان لو انا كنت افكر كيف اطلع لو انا كنت
افكر ايش العواطف راح تصير راح استخدم
اكسجين بشكل اسرع من المخزون المعلومه
فاحنا بنكون نايمين فعشان كده
الاسم كامل
وهذه المؤشر
هذا التخصص
اللي احنا هنستخدم الحين
او الاسم
عمليات نقاشه
[تصفيق]
طبعا
الحمد لله انا حاصله على 29 رقم وطني في
مجال الوصيحه وطبعا في تخصصات متعدده
الحبل
[موسيقى]
حاصل على خمسه
[تصفيق]
بعدين برجع
بخبركم فيها
طبعا هي مجموعه
انا تاهلت من المنافسه بشكل اقليمي او
محلي بعدها انتقلنا على
انتقلنا على مستوى اسوي ولكن الحمد لله في
سنه 2022
سويته او هذا الشيء مش لانها
مهندس كهرباء ما حدا اخواني له علاقه مثلا
بالغوص ولا اي شيء اذا انا دخلت المجال
بالصدفه
بالصدفه سنه
احنا عندنا هذه النعمه كيف احنا ما قربنا
ليش احنا محرومين
بديت اطور طبعا هذا الشيء
بخط الرياضه بشكل صحيح
بدات تطور نفسي شوي شوي بعده هاوي
الى 2011 المدرب اللي كانت
عندك يعني
في بطولات يسوونها
شاركت من 2011 الى 2000 2016
[موسيقى]
2016 حصلت على اول انجاز خليجي اللي هو
بطوله الشيخ حمدان بن محمد بن راشد يحبس
النفسي انه كم اطول مده ممكنه
ممكن الانسان يحبس فيها نفس تحت الامر
طبعا في فتره التدريب انا الحمد لله وصلت
الى سبعه دقائق احبس
وكملت هذا المشوار
في تخصص حبس النفس مش في الاعمال طبعا هذا
مجال ثاني مختلف جدا نفس الحين مثلا
جراحه او الجراحه عن الاسنان كلها كيف في
تخصصات مختلفه في 2018 هنا
مثل ما شفنا
التعليق او
ممكن يكون منبه لك مش ممكن يعني مثلا بعض
الخيانه والمتجاج يلا ممكن تجرب هذا ممكن
يكون هذا المفتاح لك للوصول بس مش دائما
هذه الطرق ممكن تشتغل معك
2018 نحل الزمل
بطوله عمار
ربما ان ما في خواصين كتير فعلا
انت متخصص مسابح
مثلا بتسجل لك 30 متر تشارك معانا في
الموصل
قال كده باستنزال
30 متر على الاقل بتشارك في المطار قلت لك
انا ما اشارك
معلش انت بتستنى نعرف فتعرف
احد يتجاوزني
راح اتجوزك
ونعدل التمريض
ورحت السعوديه وطلعت
الصوره
اللي ممكن اوصلها رساله متواضعه انا دائما
تخيلاتي اللي ممكن تيجي لدماغ الانسان
ممكن تطبق على هذا الرائع هذا اول شيء ومن
ضمنها طبعا في مجموعه انا عايشين في افكار
كل هذا اللي قدامنا عباره عن افكار مطوره
لو تذكروا الكوبيل اللي يعطونا اياهم في
ايام المدرسه حصلت العلوم خير عشان نتواصل
صح وصلنا عنا في عندنا لايف من هذاك من
خلال
فتخيل سرعه التطور اللي موجوده في الحلم
تخيل كل هذه الاشياء ممكن تطلع لنا مكان
نعيش فيه 70%
اللي موجود على وجه الارض وممكن ان هذا
المكان يكون مهيا من درجه حراره الماء
طبعا
[موسيقى]
الليله احنا بنعيش حياه مرض فهذا
ممكن انها تتطور واحنا موجودين هنا اليوم
كلنا
لتهيئه حياه افضل جرجير
شكرا لهذه الحصه
[تصفيق]